welcome to build with google cloud where
we build reference architectures in this
video we will build an ecommerce
platform on google cloud what are your
options stay with me to find out
[Music]
let's say you're a retailer that sells
pet products shoes cars anything did you
know that digital commerce platform can
be built and modernized in multiple ways
i am priyanka vergaria developer
advocate here at google cloud and today
let's see what your options are to build
a digital ecommerce platform on google
cloud you ready let's go
[Music]
first you can build your own ecommerce
platform on google cloud
why does this make sense because it
provides the agility to create new
capabilities using data insights and
access to machine learning and ai tools
within google cloud
there are two ways to build your own
platform you could either migrate your
existing ecommerce platform or modernize
using containers
migrate means lifting and shifting your
current platform as is into the cloud
this is the lowest risk and fastest way
to get to cloud
it is suitable for custom built
ecommerce stack leveraging heavy oss or
running on-premises and once you've
migrated you are on your path to
modernization you could choose to
migrate and improve where you can
upgrade and improve or optimize using
containerized approach
this means you're willing to move to
containers and are gradually moving to
google cloud managed services such as
gke
it sets the stage for a more seamless
modernization path to microservices on
gke if the goal is to modernize your
commerce application platform completely
for benefits of cloud and speed to
market then you would re-architect to
adopt containers using microservices
architecture
this helps you shift focus to creating
those differentiated customer
experiences for digital and omni-channel
revenue growth welcome back to architect
the commerce migration and modernization
but before we do that let's also check
out the other options the second option
is you can create a headless commerce
platform on google cloud this is where
you actually decouple the front end the
mobile app the cms etc from your backend
or your commerce layer
this approach provides flexibility to
your marketing teams to quickly alter
front-end elements to run campaigns
promotions and create most advanced
customer experience on your front end
you're building front-end experience on
google cloud and are integrating with
commerce backends from google cloud
marketplace offering partners
this unique approach offers the benefits
of the agility to launch or change
highly personalized experiences
flexibility to upgrade update or replace
your dependent systems and scale
different parts of solutions independent
of each other
as you can imagine this approach has a
low total cost of ownership smaller it
teams and is not constrained by a
monolithic roadmap and timelines to
offer new storefront features third
option you could use out-of-the-box sas
solution on google cloud marketplace
such as shopify bigcommerce or hcl
commerce this will work for you if you
require minimum customizations and can
take advantage of google cloud for
customer 360 and data insights driven
analytics which of these approaches are
you leaning towards to build your
ecommerce platform and why
share in the comments
let's dive into the first two approaches
build your own and headless commerce one
by one to understand what it takes to
build and which one makes sense for your
use case
now let's architect the build your own
migrate and improve approach
this means you're not just migrating but
also looking to break down a legacy
monolith commerce application into a set
of micro services that can help you gain
agility in launching those new features
innovate and improve customer experience
by leveraging data insights that are
powered by ai and ml capabilities
in order to do this you're going to need
to migrate and improve using
containerization
on google kubernetes engine
let's see how
you would deploy your application
servers and your database as services in
containers inside a gke cluster
you can accelerate this process of
moving to gke by using migrate for
anthos google's migration automation
tool
all your static content including the
images media assets web files will be
stored in cloud storage
any other application systems that still
exist on premises will be hooked up via
a dedicated interconnect cloud vpn or
api management
now let's see the request flow
the user makes a request from their
phone website or chat application which
then gets resolved by cloud dns to a
global anycast ip address for cloud load
balancing
cloud armor works alongside load
balancing to provide ddos protection and
web application firewall that detects
and blocks layer 7 attacks
recaptcha enterprise provides bot
protection and api defense provides
protection for abuse of apis
combination of cloud armor apogee api
defense and recapture enterprise offer
the web application and api protection
the request is validated by these it is
then sent to the web server the web
server then grabs the static content
such as your images css your javascript
to render that page from cloud storage
it also stores them in cloud cdn for
next request which helps with
performance and latency
next web server would need to interact
with the app server for business logic
such as is this item in store
the internal load balancing between the
web and application servers help
distribute the load
once the request lands on the app server
it interacts with the database to get
the response yes the item is in store
and there are four more left or
something like that
gets this information and then sends it
back to the user via web servers
now if the requests requires the app
server to gather information from a
service that is on premises then it can
make a call to the service via an api
through apigee api gateway or vpn over
the internet or just direct connectivity
to that data center
if the request was a search or
recommendations then app server
interfaces with the google retail search
or the recommendations api to present
the appropriate results to the user
architecturally build your own migrate
and improve provides you the flexibility
to add features
ability to scale easily by adding more
gke clusters during traffic spikes it
also offers applications the security
using a combination of cloud armor load
balancer recapture and api defense
from the business perspective the build
your own and migrate and improve
approach enables the integration with
the data platform which creates a strong
closed loop between the data platform
and the commerce platform
you can collect the first party customer
data from shopper interactions on their
modern digital commerce platform
to use in your data platform for
predictive analytics and marketing
activation
you can also gain insights from data in
data platform to offer personalized
shopping experiences and promotions on
the digital commerce site are you ready
to migrate and improve
we've got a link to the documentation
below to help you out now how would you
architect your migration as is or lift
and shift your ecommerce platform to
google cloud
say your priority is to move to google
cloud as quickly as possible or you have
a homegrown oss stack based on premises
in e-commerce platform that is unique
and works well and you just want to
migrate
that means you just want to migrate as
is without making any changes just get
to the cloud so you can take that first
step towards modernization
for an as-is migration like this we
recommend migrating to compute engine
virtual machines
let's see how to architect this
your request flow pretty much stays the
same except for your web and application
servers and your database you will
create your web and application servers
on compute engine managed instance
groups which will scale based on the
number of requests you receive
you will also deploy your primary and
secondary databases on compute engine
instances
this architecture offers the ability to
scale the web and app tiers
independently using the managed instance
groups and provides low latency
responses back to the end customer to
keep them engaged in their buying
journey
you have the same application security
using a combination of cloud armor load
balancer recaptcha and api defense in
addition it allows you as a retailer to
quickly meet unexpected user traffic
spikes without having a large size
deployment initially but automatically
scale easily up and down enabled by your
configuration policies are you ready to
migrate your ecommerce application as is
we've got a link in the documentation to
help you out now let's say you have
migrated to google cloud using gke or
compute engine or you're building an
entire modernized ecommerce platform
from scratch
how would you go from here to modernized
fully containerized microservices
architecture let's see all your request
flow stays the same as you saw earlier
what changes is that now you're going to
think about smaller services and
separate them out into four layers
presentation layer which could be your
single page application builder and
content
a services layer which would include
services such as sessions search account
inventory orders and anything else that
you can think of
the storage layer which would be your
storage choices for those services there
could be different storages based on the
kind of service for example cloud sql or
spanner for inventory products and maybe
firestore for sessions
cache layer would be your transient
cache using memory stored to access
recently queried data without querying
the storage layer again
you can now see the flexibility that
this architecture allows you to have you
can add and deploy any new services
anytime without affecting any other
services
you can also have different teams
working on different services in
different programming languages
lots more flexibility both from the
development side and from the business
side which leads to happy developers and
happy customers
and you have enabled your business to
have a strong close loop between the
data platform and the commerce platform
to understand customer behavior and
offer personalized experiences
another huge advantage of this approach
is the seamless integration with other
google cloud services such as workspace
maps gpa mobile android chrome devices
and more are you ready to start your
ecommerce modernization journey we've
got a link to a sample code repository
for you to get started
now let's take a deep dive into the
headless commerce solution as a retailer
you might want to own and control the
front end for providing an engaging and
differentiated shopping experience and
leverage the ready-to-use back-end
commerce building blocks for
capabilities such as product catalog
pricing promotions cards shipping
accounts and other things
in this fast-paced world where user
behavior changes every day
headless commerce approach is
increasingly preferred for speed to
market you can easily launch new
experiences quickly and benefit from
innovations and back-end capabilities
added by our partners on google cloud
marketplace such as commerce tools
how would you architect this well let's
see the user would have the same secured
experience using web application and api
security solution
the front end is deployed on gke or
cloud run and can use cloud storage for
static assets and firestore or cloud sql
for your dynamic storage and database
options
interacting with the recommendations api
and retail search for an engaging
product discovery and shopping
experience that would reduce search
abandonment and increase sales
conversions commerce tools platform from
marketplace serves as the backend for
commerce operations it provides over 300
apis for e-commerce back-end needs such
as your products categories orders and
other such things this approach is an
alternative to build or buy approach as
it offers a right mix of both approaches
to realize a solution that enables brand
differentiation flexibility and agility
to help you get started with headless
commerce we've built an end-to-end demo
check it out below and let us know how
it goes
we just looked at the different options
to build a modern ecommerce platform on
google cloud depending on your situation
you can choose to migrate as is to
compute engine vms migrate and improve
using containers
build an entirely modern microservices
based architecture creating
containerized services or use partners
offered services to adopt headless
commerce approach
any direction you take is a success and
a great start to gain agility in
launching new features innovation and
improving customer experience by
leveraging data insights powered by ai
and ml and tools such as retail search
and recommendations ai
now it's your turn go build the headless
commerce demo with the documentation and
a full sample code repository linked
below if you like this video then i hope
you completely destroy those like and
subscribe buttons to let us know i
cannot wait to build more stuff with you
[Music]
[Music]
you